okay I'm gonna clarify something that is
coming up as a question a lot in regards
to the video that I did on Drew
Barrymore in particular people are
referencing the last time there was a
registry 2007-2008 there were a number
of late night talk show hosts uh
particularly say Conan O'Brien I believe
also Stephen Colbert who did continue to
do their shows even when the writers
Were Striking but they just eliminated
the script and stuff and they improvised
everything like to the point that Conan
O'Brien was fulfilling Time by spinning
his wedding ring on his desk now people
have asked either why can't she do
something like that or have tried to say
why was that okay and this isn't now I
don't have a hundred percent certainty
on this because to get 100 certainty I
would have to find the exact strike
rules that were issued in 2007 and I can
find reference to them but the exact
ordering I can't find but my suspicion
is because new strike rules are written
for every strike they probably close
whatever a loophole allows for that last
time because even the late night talk
show host who did it last time aren't
doing it this time so I think that's a
closed loop